ON THE COMMITTEE ON LABOR AND
EMPLOYMENT I WILL CALL THIS
MEETING TO ORDER --
WE NEED ONE MORE FORM OF THE
VICE CHAIR WILL BE PRESIDING AND
WE WILL SO THAT I MAY PRESENT AB
[inaudible]
FIFTY SIX S..
AND WE WILL START AS A
SUBCOMMITTEE.
SO MISTER CHAIR.
PRESENT WHEN YOU ARE READY
.
I THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS.
AND PLEASE BE BEFORE THE PRESENT
AB FIFTEEN SIXTY FIVE THIS IS A
BILL THAT ADDS ONTO.
A LAST YEAR'S --
SIGNED LEGISLATION AB SEVENTEEN
A ONE THAT DEALS WITH WAGE THAT
SPECIFICALLY THAT BILL SAID
THAT.
A IN CONSTRUCTION WHEN WAGE
WERE PAID BY SUB CONTRACTOR THAT
THE GENERAL CONTRACTOR WOULD
TAKE ON LIABILITY.
ARE IN THOSE CASES --
AB FIFTEEN SIXTY FIVE BUILT ON
THAT BUT THE PROVIDE CLARITY.
OF FOR ALL PARTIES INVOLVED AND
THROUGH A HOST OF CONVERSATIONS
IN NEGOTIATIONS --
WE BELIEVE THAT WE HAVE IMPROVE
SEVENTEEN NO ONE UP FROM THE
PERSPECTIVE OF ALL PARTIES ARE
INVOLVED.
ON THAT WILL CONTINUE TO ENSURE
THAT WAGES WILL BE PAID THAT
THEY'LL BE CLARITY ABOUT HOW
WHAT RECORDS PAYROLL RECORDS AND
OTHERS SET A A SUBCONTRACTOR.
WOULD NEED TO PROVIDE TO THE
GENERAL CONTRACTOR.
AND I WE BELIEVE THAT THIS IS IN
THE BEST INTERESTS OF OF
AND RESPECTING THE NEEDS OF OUR
EMPLOYERS IN OUR INDUSTRY AS
WELL.
I I ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE ON A.
B. C. FIFTEEN SIXTY FIVE PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL --
EMPHASIS UP WE HAD EIGHTY
BERNACCHI ON BEHALF OF THE
CONTRACTORS GROUP.
AND THE CONTRACTORS ASSOCIATION
AND NICK COMER ROHDE ON BEHALF
OF THE COMPANY BUILDING INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR IBOOK.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS EDDIE BERNACCHI MAP THE
NATIONAL ELECTORAL CONTRACTORS
ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATIVE CONFERENCE OF
PLUMBING HEATING PIPING
INDUSTRY.
THE WALLS CEILING ALLIANCE
SONORA CALIFORNIA ALLIED TRADES
--
THIS BILL CONTAINS MUCH IN THE
AREA OF WHAT PAYROLL RECORDS
MUST BE PROVIDED BY
SUBCONTRACTORS TO THE GENERAL
CONTRACTORS.
HELP PREVENT THIS NEW SECTION OF
LOBBYING USE OF SUBTERFUGE TO
HOLD --
PROGRESS PAYMENTS BACK FROM
SUBCONTRACTORS UNLAWFULLY --
THE APPRECIATE WORKING WITH THE
AUTHOR AND THE OTHER --
MEMBERS OF THE CONSTRUCTION
COMMUNITY TO COME UPON LANGUAGE
THAT WILL WORK FOR US ENSURE
THAT --
CONTRACTORS WHO IMPLEMENT WITH
NEW STATUTES ARE PAID ON TIME SO
THEY CAN CONTINUE WORKING AND
PAY THEIR EMPLOYEES MOVE ON TO
THE NEXT PROJECTS SO.
WITH THAT WE WOULD URGE DRIVE
VOTE AND THAT I HOPE THAT YOU
CAN SUPPORT US ON THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
I'M NICK CAMMARATA BEHALF
CALIFORNIA BUILDING INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL WOULD LIKE.
TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING
THIS MEASURE FORWARD AYE WE
VIEWED THAT SUBDIVISION AGE IN
THE CURRENT CODE SECTION.
CREATED SOME CONFUSION AND WE
THINK THAT'S REMOVAL OF CLEAR
THAT HAPPEN.
ALSO AKKI AFTER [inaudible]
ECHO THE COMMENTS OF ANY PER
GNOCCHI AND URGE YOUR AYE VOTE
ON THE BILL.
ALRIGHT I THINK WILL GO INTO
THIS TIME TO ESTABLISH A CORE
[inaudible]
IT'S CALLED [inaudible]
THURMOND.
PRESENT FLORA HERE GONZALEZ
FLETCHER JONES SAWYER.
KALRA [inaudible]
REVERSE [inaudible]
STEINORTH [inaudible]
QUORUM.
I THINK YOU.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
THE WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
BRING BACK TO THE COMMITTEE IN
THE QUEST FOR THE COMMITTEE
[inaudible]
A SECOND.
JARED LIKE TO CLOSE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR VOTE.
I THINK YOU [inaudible]
COLORFUL.
MOTION IS RECOMMEND SENATE
AMENDMENTS BE CONCURRED IN
THURMAN HIGH THURMAN AYE FLORA
AYE FLORA AYE GONZALEZ FLETCHER
JONES SAWYER.
KALRA.
KALRA AYE REBUS.
LEAVE US AYE STEINORTH STEINORTH
AYE.
I IF THESE ARE THE BILL IS OUT.
BELIEVABLE FOR OTHER MEMBERS
THAT ON THANK YOU SO CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
.
GONZALEZ FLETCHER AYE
[inaudible]
JONES SAWYER.
I'VE BEEN JONES SAWYER
[inaudible]
I ALRIGHT THE MEETING IS
ADJOURNED THINKS